I'm going to make a promise to you in
the next 7 seconds that nobody on
YouTube is making. Then I'm going to
prove it. As you can see here, $242,000
in the last 120 days trading NQ futures
only on the 5-minute time frame taking
just one trade per day. Let me quickly
refresh this so you can see this is not
a screenshot and this is all my previous
4 months.
And by the time this timer hits zero,
you know my entire strategy and I'll
show you every single day of this week
three trade that I took two trades that
I skipped 100% win rate on this week on
the trades that I took. If you can't
open your chart tomorrow and execute
this, that's on me, not on you. And now,
let's get straight into it. I trade only
NQ only on the 5-minute chart and only
on the New York session. This is the
base of this strategy. You can see that
I only have two indicators on my chart.
This is the sessions indicator. You can
copy my settings here and this is my
personal indicator. This is only showing
the higher time frame EMAs on my
5-minute chart. I already did a video on
how to set up this indicator. I will
leave the link in the description down
below on how to set up this higher time
frame EMAs on the 5-minute chart. The
first rule of the strategy is before the
New York session open, we need to define
our bias if it bullish or bearish and we
do that using these EMAs. If these EMAs
are going downwards and the price is
below them, we will be looking for
shorts. If the price is above this EMAs
and pointing upwards, we will be looking
for longs. If these EMAs are flat,
overlapping or too close to each other,
we will not be taking a trade simply
because that shows that the market is
indecisive and we don't have a clear
bias. That's why we will not be taking a
trade when these EMAs are flat,
overlapping or mixed and this ensures
that we are always on the right side of
the market. Now for rule number two, we
need to see a pullback in the opposite
direction of our bias. Plus, we want to
see a fair value gap inside this
pullback. Like we see here, this day our
bias was bearish. Price is under all the
EMAs. We can see a pullback here in the
opposite direction of the trend and we
can see here fair value gap inside this
pullback. That means if we are looking
for shorts like this example, we want to
find the last bullish fair value gap in
this pullback. And now for rule number
three, if we break this fair value gap
to the downside, that means we inverted
this fair value gap. We enter when this
5-minute candle is over and we put our
stop loss at the previous candle that
inverted this fair value gap. That means
at this candle and we either target
previous liquidity like we have here on
this example or if we don't have a near
previous liquidity, we simply target two
Rs. And don't forget, please wait for
the 5-minute candle to be over to enter.
Don't enter in the middle of the candle
because it can wick and the price can
continue going up. And now, let me walk
you through all the days of this week
starting from Monday, the day that I
didn't take a trade until today was
Friday, the 1st of May. So, let me show
you what happened Monday. We can see
here for rule number one that the bias
is already defined because the EMAs are
pointing up. The price is over the
1-hour EMA as you can see right here.
So, rule number one is checked. For rule
number two, I kept looking for a fair
value gap inside this pullback that is
in the opposite of the direction of the
market, but I couldn't find it. But
later in the afternoon, a fair value gap
was formed, but the problem with the
setup is I noticed that the candles are
becoming much and much smaller. That
means there is no volume in the market.
It was going to be a winning trade, but
I didn't want to risk it. So, you can
see here we can put the stop loss under
the previous candle and we can target
this previous liquidity right here. That
would have been a winning trade, but I
didn't want to risk it. And for everyone
who was asking me in the DMs why I
didn't take the trade, I simply wasn't
comfortable taking this trade. That's
it. So, Monday I didn't take a trade.
Let's jump into Tuesday.
Here after market open, we can clearly
see that the price is under all the EMAs
and they are all pointing downwards.
A fair value gap was formed right here
in this pullback in the opposite of our
bias because our bias is bearish. I
entered right after breaking this fair
value gap and inverting it. I put the
stop loss here at this previous candle
and simply targeted near previous
liquidity. Let's play this trade out.
It went to take profit in 25 minutes.
After that, I closed my charts and
called it a day. This was Tuesday, the
28th. I made 5.6k on it and this is the
power of the strategy. You only take one
trade per day and you call it a day. You
can go live your life. You don't need to
be glued in front of the charts for all
day. You simply take a trade exactly
like this every single day without any
discretion, purely mechanical. You can
see clearly the fair value gap in front
of your eyes. You can clearly see the
bias using the EMAs and if all
conditions are met, you simply execute
the trade. That's it. Now, let's go to
the next day.
On this day, Wednesday, I noticed that
the EMAs are so close to each other.
That means the market is indecisive. I
drew this fair value gap here in this
pullback and kept waiting. Maybe the
EMAs will start pointing downwards, but
it didn't happen. You see here that the
EMAs are still flat. That's why I didn't
take this trade. And all the traders
that took a trade on this day are simply
traders who forced this setup. That was
Wednesday, the 29th of April. You can
see here it's blank. That means I didn't
take a trade. Let's jump to the next
day.
Man, this was a tricky day for some
traders. We can clearly see that the
EMAs are pointing upwards. That means my
bias will be bullish for the day. I
started looking for a fair value gap
inside this bearish pullback. You can
clearly see it right here. Now, let's
play the price.
Still nothing.
Now, we can clearly see that the second
fair value gap has formed. Let me
quickly remove this. You can clearly see
that the EMAs are still pointing
upwards. That's why I entered. I put my
stop loss on this previous candle right
here and I targeted previous liquidity.
Let's play the price out.
And straight to TP. This was not a
textbook setup especially with the EMAs,
but you need to notice the little
details. EMAs right here are not so
close together like the previous day
when I decided to not take a trade. Look
how much these EMAs are close together.
Look here, you can see right here
clearly that the EMAs are pointing
upwards. This was a huge liquidity grab
if you want to call it like that and
this was on Thursday, the 30th of April.
I made 4.2k with it. Let's jump to the
next day which is today.
Today, we can clearly see that the EMAs
are pointing upwards and stacked. The
price is above the EMAs, so my bias will
be bullish. This is the first rule. Now,
let's see the market open. It was a huge
candle. We can clearly see here on the
left that we have an unmitigated fair
value gap. That's why I entered. I put
my stop loss on the fair value gap
because the candle open was so big. My
stop loss doesn't exceed usually 300
ticks. I entered, put my stop loss on
the fair value gap and we did go
straight to TP. That was the trade I
took today, Friday, the 1st of May. I
made 4.3k with it. Now, let me do a
quick recap to end the video. Like I
said, we only trade NQ only on the
5-minute time frame and only on the New
York session. Before market open, we
need to define our bias if it's bullish
or bearish. We do that with the help of
the higher time frame EMA indicator that
I have here. If the EMAs are pointing
upwards, we go long. If the EMAs are
pointing downwards, we go obviously
short. If the EMAs are too close to each
other, mixed like this and flat, we
don't take a trade at all. Rule number
two, we need to find a fair value gap in
the pullback opposite of the direction
of the market. That means we are here
obviously bullish. We want to find a
fair value gap inside this pullback that
we have here. Rule number three, if we
broke and inverted this fair value gap,
we go in.
We put our stop loss either on the
candle that inverted the fair value gap,
the previous candle or the swing low.
That depends solely on market structure
and also on the risk appetite everyone
have. And please, before I forget,
please make sure to enter after the
5-minute inversion candle is over. I see
too many people rushing and entering in
the middle of the candle and simply
price turns against them. Now for the
TP, if we have near previous liquidity
more than two Rs, we target it. If not,
we simply target two Rs. This is the
whole strategy. And don't forget, this
EMA indicator is free. I will leave the
link in the description down below on
how to set it up for free. Make sure to
subscribe, drop your questions in the
comments. I make sure to reply on
everyone. Follow me on Instagram. Let's
meet on the next one.